thank you all for being here my name is
Christina Lee and I am an Android
engineer at Pinterest and if you've seen
some of my former talks I've done a
modified version of this talk it was
shorter fit into 20 minutes the material
was really well-received so I wanted to
expand on that so I'm gonna cover some
of what I've talked about before bear
with me but I'm also gonna dive a little
deeper into areas I previously didn't
have time to talk about so with that I
just want to start by looking at the
Kotlin type system the reason for that
is that so much of the good things that
Kotlin gives us comes from the type
system now if you've never seen a visual
representation of what the Kotlin type
system looks like it's something like
this two things to point out is down
there at the bottom we see the nothing
type and everything flows from the
nothing type it is the subtype of all
types up at the top we have any question
mark and everything culminates in any
question mark it's a super type of all
types and then in between we have our
you know primitives if we want to call
them that like int and then we also have
children and parent classes in the way
we would assume so this is the shape of
the type system it's very neatly order
there are no exceptions here now a note
before we go any further I think we as
developers often use the word class and
type interchangeably and that's actually
not correct in some cases it can be
correct for instance in this line this
first line we have class is string and
so is the type as soon as in Kotlin you
introduce the idea of no ability though
the class on the type they start to
diverge so in this second line string is
still the class but string question mark
is now the type and if you go further
and do anything at all with collections
you get into a situation where the same
class will generate nearly infinite
types in these three examples the class
is always list but as you can see in the
third line the type is a list of a list
of a pair of an int of a list of a
string so with that let's go ahead and
take a look at why we care
I always make the same joke which is
that I must acknowledge null ability in
any talk I do about Kotlin so here it is
why do we care about having a really
orderly type system well we're all used
to behavior like this wherein we can
assign something that's an INT to
something with a type number and we can
do that because we have a subtype to
super type relationship
well the same thing gets us null safety
so here if we declare something that's
knowable and we try to assign it to
something that's not knowable it's not
going to compile and the reason for that
is it breaks the exact principle that we
have in this line which is if you
remember that type diagram string is a
sub or is the sub type of string
question mark but not the other way
around so we get null safety which we
all know and love
yay four types now let's take a look at
some of those other areas just to
establish a basis you you saw the
nothing type there and you might wonder
why you care I mean it's kind of cool
it's a fun word I and and the reason in
short of why we care about the nothing
type is code like this if you've used
Kotlin you might have used this function
to do why would you use it well if you
don't have it you immediately get a
compilation error you have some declared
return type you're not fulfilling it and
you need to before you can compile but
if you're building out your code and you
don't want to have to do this just yet
in order to get the compilation then you
might go ahead and do something like to
do now this should bake the question why
does this work like what magic is
happening under the hood that suddenly
lets me compile code that doesn't
actually have the return type I'm
requesting and the answer is well this
is the magic so in short what is the to
do function it's a function that only
throws an error that's all it does it
throws an error and what is the return
type while the return type is nothing
now this may seem a little strange but
we're actually used to this behavior
already so in a line like this where we
taking something nullable and then we
use this Elvis operator to say if it's
not null use this value if it is null do
this thing over here well we know that
we are short-circuiting the logic
because the
on the very next line we can use that as
a not null type now if if we got rid of
this check and then we try to do
something with the knowable it's gonna
give us that error you can't do that
it's not safe but if we have this value
like so and we throw then we can use it
as if it's not null and the reason for
that is that because the compiler knows
that you will never reach that second
line because if it is null the program
would have thrown the exception and
short-circuited well to do and the
nothing type that's exactly what they
represent
they represent the notion that a
function will never complete normally
and so in this code you'll actually see
it that on the left hand side it says
that it's unreachable the reason for
this is because to do returns nothing
and nothing means that it will never
complete normally ergo you will never
reach that assignment because as soon as
you go and try to evaluate the to do
function you're gonna get an exception
and it's gonna stop that's why this code
on the left hand side is unreachable so
that's to do it represents the idea that
anywhere that you have this nothing type
the code will never complete normally
okay taking a look at any verses object
we get a lot of questions about this any
is the default super type of a class you
can declare a class like this is this
valid code but you can also declare it
like this and give it an explicit super
type so these are equivalent
now there's also this nicety around any
which is that our primitive system to us
as end users appears exactly the same as
our reference type system so in Java you
might be used to having value types and
reference types and those diverge but in
Kotlin that's handled for us so under
the hood that is all still happening but
as far as we're concerned everything is
acting in in a linear way as a reference
type that bubbles up to any so if we
have an integer like this which would be
a a primitive in Java we can still
assign it to any so again there are no
exceptions to this under the hood we
have that boxing and unboxing going on
but we don't have to deal with that now
any is not the same as object at runtime
you're going to see an object there but
it's different because it's screen
so if you look at the declaration for
any you see this is it this is all that
there is there and it has exactly three
functions which is hash code equals and
two string now object on the other hand
has a lot more than that for instance it
has this notify function if you try to
use object in Pilot it's immediately
going to tell you that's a really bad
idea
the the idea of any is not that you're
using this for complicated logic it is
usually just a subtype to super type to
something else you care about so using
objects in Kotlin is no no you should
try to avoid it but you can because
these things are based on the same
implementation now I always call this
out because sometimes there's confusion
about any any it is indeed the default
super type of classes but it is
different from any question mark namely
you cannot assign something that's any
question mark to something that's any
it's not an exception the type system is
rigorous there are no exceptions to this
shadowed null hierarchy okay unit this
is the part that I find really really
fun I've inserted this huge block quote
here you don't need to read it you can
it's a great quote but you don't need to
because I'll go through the pieces of it
basically the gist of this is that unit
and void more or less represent the
exact same concept and that concept is
that whatever function returns those two
things is there only as a side-effect if
it wasn't a side-effect II function it
would return a value
because it's not returning anything it
must be printing to the console or
hitting the network or modifying the
database or some other side-effect II
you know functionality and so that's why
you use void and unit that's what the
concept exists for but there's a
difference in how that concept is
implemented namely void is the idea that
you return absolutely nothing if a
function is you know public static void
main you're returning nothing from that
function unit is the idea that you
return nothing useful and I know that
sounds super arbitrary and like okay why
do we haven't cared that's that's a
ridiculous and and the reason we care in
short is generics
because unit if you go in and look at it
this is the declaration and they take
doing nothing like any or nothing useful
thing very seriously like the only thing
you can do is if you have unit you can
print it that's all you get from this
you'll also notice that it has the
object keyword which in Kotlin
represents a a singleton so there's
there's one instance of this thing
floating around and the only thing that
instance can do is be printed to the
console so it really doesn't do anything
useful but it has exactly the same form
as everything else in Kotlin and because
of that we can use it in generics in a
way that we couldn't with void
so with void in Java you may notice that
you have to use a capital v void type if
you want to use it as a parameter to a
generic this isn't awful but it does
mean that you can't use that keyword
that you're used to using in all of your
functions and namely you have to go in
and you know start changing the return
types and then explicitly where you're
returning the type parameter of capital
v void now with unit none of that has to
happen we return unit by default so here
I've done it explicitly but you don't
need to do that you can do this and it's
exactly equivalent I can store it as a
parameter somewhere I can use it as a
type nothing changes unit is an object
just like anything else it's a class
with a single instantiation so I can use
it the same way I would use any other
generic parameter and that's nice
because it gets us something like this
I'm not doing lowercase u unit and
uppercase u unit I'm just doing unit
nothing changes and so this is nice it's
not the end of the world to do this with
void but it's a little less than ideal
okay that brings me to platform types
has anybody heard of platform types yeah
two people ok great three people this is
going to be fun then fun because you're
going to hate them that's awesome it's
gonna it's gonna be great
oh so we started the presentation with
this snippet of code and I kind of said
ah you can have this thing or you can
have this thing and that implicitly
implies that there's two things but of
course I was lying to you as any good
speaker will do and there's actually
this third representation here and so we
have this idea of something that's
knowable and we have the
idea of something that's not knowable
and then we have a third possibility and
what that third possibility means is I
have no clue whether you are knowable or
not I really don't have any idea and so
if you're reading this in in you know
English which is my first language then
it acts as English does which is that if
something's nullable you can think of it
as a question string like maybe it's
there maybe it's not you don't know like
could be string could be knowing I don't
know I the not knowable case there's no
punctuation it's a statement this is a
string and then of course there's
platform types which have no idea what
they are and there's an exclamation
point because it's like oh my god where
am i what am i I don't even know and
it's screaming because it has no idea
it's running around frantically and so
thank you
punctuation hopefully that Association
will stick with you and haunt your
nightmares so it is important to know
that this is a notation and not a syntax
with platform types you can't say that
you don't know anything
which is ironic as a developer because I
would love to say that often but you
can't do this you can't profess that you
are not proficient at knowing whether
something is null or not this is
generated for you you you might see it
in output you might see it in crashes
but you cannot instantiate this platform
type so when would you get a platform
type like what scenario do you not know
whether something is knowable or not
well not to name names but some
languages do not require you to track
the null ability of what you're using
and so you would get platform types when
you're working with those languages now
here's an example I have this function
you can look at it it only returns an
ArrayList there's nothing crazy going on
here and the thing to note here is this
line here and this one too because you
notice that I can work with it as if
it's null Abul and it compiles there are
no warnings I can also work with it as
if it's not knowable and it also
compiles in there no more
now if that seems normal you can quickly
realize that it's not when you compare
it to any other Kotlin code here I've
created a list in the same way that I
was doing in Java
now if I work with it as nullable it
correctly identifies that as the correct
behavior if I try to leave that off it
Flags it it says you're gonna get an NP
Eid please don't do this you need to
address this situation and if I go ahead
and switch that type so that it's no
longer knowable well here it says you're
being redundant please remove this you
don't need it
so again in Kotlin we cannot work with
it in both ways it'll tell us that one
way or the other way is wrong but with
platform types because it has no idea
which way is right it'll let you choose
whichever one you want and you're not
gonna get any warnings about that now
why do you care well this is why we all
care because and here's a handy chart
for you if you're wrong it'll crash yay
so that's not great um because it allows
you to work with it as if it's null and
as if it's not null if you say this
thing is not null and actually you're
wrong and it is null well you get your
crash there's a 50% chance that it works
out for you in these two cases where you
predictably say okay it is not null and
it isn't null or it is no and it is no
those cases work out and that's great
and then there's you know these two
other cases where either it crashes or
you're doing redundant work so that's
not ideal
now you may seem worried by this I was a
little bit concerned wondering why
JetBrains would do this to us
we heard that Kotlin will get rid of
NPEs and now we have platform types and
they crash our code if we're wrong that
seems awful and an answer to that is
well the language guiding principles if
you're not familiar with them these are
the four guiding principles of Kotlin
which is that it should be concise
pragmatic safe and interoperable now
those are all great things but
unfortunately when it comes to Java
Interop we get a situation like this
where
would require us to break some of the
other language principles namely if you
assume in the safest case that
everything is always knowable you have a
like a exponential function for that if
you have a list the list itself could be
knowable or it could not and then
everything inside if that could also be
nullable or not so a list of a string
has four different permutations where
both of them are null neither of them
are null one is no not the other etc and
that's a list of strings that's a pretty
simple case if you get things that are
more complex than that you quickly get
this string of possible null ability
that you have to go through an unwrap
every single time you call anything from
Java and that's not very pragmatic it's
definitely not concise and it means that
you probably are going to hold back from
doing any interoperation with Java
because it is painful and so we
sacrifice a bit of safety no worse than
what was already in Java in order to
give us these three other language
principles now you may say okay I
understand why they did it but I don't
like it and I would like to not crash
and we have some suggestions for that so
best practices for platform types
annotate your java code the reason for
that is if you annotate your Java code
so let's go in here and go ahead and add
the nullable annotation like so you're
gonna see it is no longer a platform
type the platform type disappeared it
now correctly knows that this is a
nullable type and it won't compile so if
you have not null or nullable
annotations in your java code platform
types go away they don't exist because a
platform type simply means I don't know
whether this is knowable or not if you
provide that information you don't need
this type that says I don't know because
now you do know now we use a lot of
things from other people so if you can't
go in and add null ability annotations
to your Java code the next best thing to
do is explicitly type anything that
you're getting from Java the reason for
that is that if you don't you will get
an npe like this and it can be confusing
because it doesn't look like any
thing here is nullable we don't have the
question mark we don't have any of that
and so you might look at that and say
how is this giving me an NP e it doesn't
look knowable now if you explicitly type
the code coming back from Java you're
gonna get a much better exception
specifically if you go ahead and add a
list of string which is what you're
expecting to get back and it's not that
it'll give you this very nice warning
that says illegal State exception you
told me this was not null but it is null
and it'll point to this line in
particular in this case it'll point to
wherever you first use that thing in the
wrong way so here they're on lines next
to each other but it's very feasible
that I get this thing from Java and then
I don't use it until 20 lines later the
npe would be all the way down at the
bottom of the file and you would have to
track it back to this source whereas if
you explicitly type it you're always
getting the npe at the line that was
problematic so it's not like foolproof
but it's something that can help you at
least debug if you can't get rid of them
altogether okay
recap the type system is cool we've
learned a little bit about unit any
nothing and platform types are dangerous
but we're stuck with them okay so moving
on to generics which is where we'd use a
lot of these types I have a little ditty
because it's the afternoon and I want to
wake you up and it goes something like
this
ABCD efg T is a type parameter band any
question mark yeah and and what that
means is that if you use T as a type
parameter like this
the default upper bound is any question
mark now there's a question mark there
and yes you're right if you don't give
any upper bound to your generic T you
have to work with it as if it's notable
if you don't want to work with it as if
it's nullable go ahead and give it an
upper bound of any instead of any
question mark and now you can work with
it as if it's not null everything goes
as planned now a few other things to get
out of the way if you have more than one
constraint normally if we have one we
would do something like fuzzy like this
and it would be on that left-hand side
if you have more than one constraint
though they get kicked out to a where
clause on the right-hand side like so
nothing crazy going on here it just
helps with readability okay now we get
to the fun stuff
type erasure it's an awful word for a
very trivial subject it's not the worst
thing but it sounds really bad when you
read it so what is type erasure Kotlin
just like java has type erasure the
reason we have it is for performance if
you don't have to keep hold of all the
types then you know that saves you on
your Perfect's what does that mean for
you as a developer well if you haven't
hit type erasure yet it means that you
get something like this where if you
have some generic passed in and then at
the time you're using it you try to
check what type it is it's gonna say I
can't check the type because I don't
know it I threw that type out and so I
can't tell you whether this is indeed a
list of an int anymore you might say
okay well what do i do then like how do
I work with this how do I know if it's a
list and the answer is you use star
projections and what star projections do
is they say I don't care what's inside
this collection just let me know if it's
actually a collection so a star
projection means you have no information
about a generic at all and and so you
can do something like this if list is
list star and what that means is enter
this if statement if there's any sort of
list they have no idea what's in it it
could be an object of straying an int
just enter if it's a list and this is
great because now we get to this line
but it's really really easy to set
yourself up for failure with star
projections and the reason for that is
is that you can enter a list like this
and then get overconfident you said
enter this if statement if it's a list I
know nothing about what's in the list
just enter if it's any sort of list but
if you go ahead I didn't get confident
and say okay if it's a list it must be a
list of int that's the only thing it
could possibly be and you cast it the
cast will always succeed always even if
it's a list of strings this cast will
succeed the
reason it will succeed is because
there's nothing there to check whether
you are right or wrong
we've erased all of that information so
if you say it's a list of int well
nobody's there to prove you wrong
there's no type information so they're
gonna say sure okay you said it was a
list of int well we'll go with that and
that means that later on once again you
can get errors because well this will
always succeed this line here when you
actually go to use it it'll crash if
you're wrong so be careful with star
projections but they're there if you
need them all right now this is where we
get into the fun stuff
I mean type erasure was fun but this I
think is pretty relatable for a lot of
people who have been using Kotlin for a
little bit of time it's hard to see on
this screen but you've written an
interface it just has a single function
and you're using it and it works and
that's awesome and then you see the
squiggly and it says the type parameter
can have out variants like I have no
idea what that is but it sounds like a
great idea
so you add it nothing changes so I guess
that's fine like nothing changed it
didn't kill the code it's still compiles
so we'll leave it doesn't seem
imminently harmful but you might also
then be asking yourself like what does
this word even do I don't understand
like you told me to add it and I did and
nothing changed and so I set up this
example to show you what it does here
the only relevant piece is that this
first function takes T as an argument
the second one returns to you
and the third one takes it as an
argument and returns it it does both now
I have no constraint on T and
everything's working if I go ahead and
add that out keyword you're gonna see
that in both locations that we take T as
an argument we get a compilation error
okay we can go ahead and try in in both
locations that we return to you we now
have a compilation error so that's
curious if we have no constraints you
know we can use it anywhere if we have
this constraint we can't use it as an
argument if we have this one we can't
return it
okay so cool we know what it does now we
can move
except for that bakes the question like
why why do we care at all where T is
placed like why does that matter and the
answer is variance it's telling us
something about the variance of the
generic parameter and if you're now
asking what is variance well I am glad
that you asked I am here to oblige so
variance tells you something about how
two things with the same base type but
different type parameters relate to each
other and namely I think sometimes
people get confused and they think that
variance is how a relates to B but it's
not that it's how foo a relates to
foobie same base class two different
type parameters okay so I'm gonna throw
a block of code at you we'll walk
through it don't panic but here it is
all right these are all three types of
variances there's only three so we can
get through them and these are the three
well walk through each one now namely
you can go ahead and read this code like
you're probably doing right now
but the reason the code is on screen is
because the part I care about is the
block of red that's what we're going to
focus on the words don't matter it's
what's lit up in red so the invariant
case the invariant case is when we don't
have an out or an in modifier we just
say T and what that means is that it
means to be an exact type match so
you'll see if here I can show you what
this looks like it's just 1 and then 2
extends from 1 and 3 extends from 2 so
nothing crazy 2 has to be assigned to 2
it's the only one that works if it's not
an exact match they don't compile this
case doesn't compile this case doesn't
compile it has to be an exact match okay
so that's invariant however there's also
something called covariant and covariant
means that subtyping is preserved so if
a is a subtype of B then foo a is also a
subtype of food B specifically we see
that this middle case continues to
succeed the exact match will always work
but the
case is now also succeeding and we see
that three is a subtype of two so
producer of three is also a subtype of
producer - that is our covariant case
and the last one is contravariant now
the beginning of that word should give
you a clue contra in contrast to it
flips the subtyping so if a is a subtype
of B we flip it and now foo B is a
subtype of food a it's not intuitive so
anytime you see contra just think
whatever I thought it was I was wrong
I'm gonna do the opposite and you'll
probably write in that case so again
this middle case it works it will always
work that's the invariant case but now
we see this flipped case which is that
one is a super type of two and so
consumer one is now a subtype of
consumer two they're opposites that
relationship is inverted okay that's
still a lot but to put that into English
words and like put it in a sentence that
hopefully is a little bit more possible
why do we care about variants and why do
we care about where T is in out
relationships well it's because out
means that it is covariant which means
that the subtyping is preserved now we
can only ever make that guarantee if
that T parameter occurs in certain
locations if it occurs in other
locations that promise is broken
ergo out means that we can strain it to
those producing locations now on the
other hand in means that it's
contravariant which means that it's
subtyping is flipped and again we can
only make that promise if T occurs in
given locations which is why the in key
word makes it so that we can only use T
in those consuming physicians okay now
that still doesn't tell you why we
actually care and the reason for that is
because in a world without variants life
is really tedious and it's not much fun
specifically we always have to have
exact matches so mutable lists you both
read to it and write to it so it's the
invariant case there's no outer in key
word
here which means it always has to be an
exact match so specifically you cannot
assign a mutable list of strings to a
mutable list of any now that makes sense
for a mutable list because we're reading
and writing so we want to make sure
we're reading and writing the exact same
type of thing but if we're reading
something only as in a list case it's
really really annoying if we can't
assign a list of strings to something
with the type list of any that doesn't
make much sense and so indeed if you go
in and look at lists you see that it has
the out parameter on the e and that's
why this code works we can assign a list
of strings to a list of any and this is
safe so the TLDR on variance is that it
allows us to be more flexible without
giving up any of the safety that we know
and love of the language and this is a
big caveat to variance which is that it
exists to protect you from everybody
else in this room unfortunately it does
not exist to protect you from yourself
you're gonna have to find something else
to deal with that and and what that
means is I've set up this example where
I have one parameter that has in one
that has out and one that has neither
and again the only thing on this slide
that matters is not the word it's what's
lit up in red so specifically a
constructor is neither covariant or
contravariance I can use all of these
things and they're not lit up in red a
bow which is a you know public in this
case public by default it has a getter
and so this this in marked T is failing
and likewise a var is something that has
a gutter and a setter it uses it in both
the in and the out locations so both the
in and out versions are breaking okay so
that's fine so far now what I've done is
I've copied this entire block and I've
pasted it here and the only thing I've
changed is I've added a private keyword
to all of those and you'll notice that
none of them error anymore so if I take
it off we get the same error if I put
private we don't and that's because
again variance describes that outer
communication that you have with people
consuming your code it doesn't apply to
anything that's
private or internal to that class now
the same thing applies to functions I
have just created a bunch of
permutations
if I remove private we get the same
error that we would expect if I add it
back it all works so all of this is to
say that generic applies to people
considered that variance applies to
people consuming your code it does not
apply to you with private internal state
okay now if you've heard anything about
variants in Kotlin it's probably that
Java has you site variance and and
Kotlin has declaration site variance and
those words probably mean nothing to you
so I'll tell you what they mean
specifically declaration site variance
is nice because here I am declaring T
and I'm also telling you what its
variances it has out variance its
covariant and so that means that when I
go ahead and use it I can use it I don't
need to do anything I just say okay a
small dog is a subtype of dog so I can
assign this this is great now in in Java
int Kotlin - you still have the ability
to do you site variance and what that
means is if I build some class the in
variant case it's not modified in any
way then at the point at which I use
that class I can give you information
about its variance so here I've added
the out keyword and here I've added the
in keyword now once again if I remove
them it doesn't compile because it would
have to be an exact match if it was in
variant but if I do this you cite
projection of the variance
I can now assign something that's int to
something that's number likewise with
the in case if I have nothing it's a
compilation error but if I have this you
cite projection I now get that extra
latitude to assign a number to an int
okay so if you are familiar with Java
generics it's worth noting that these
are equivalent if you need a way to to
remember this you can look at the
acronym PE see s PEX is how I pretend
pronounce it in my head I don't know how
you would pronounce it in your head but
it basically says producer extends
consumer super and what that means is
that this out keyword same as question
mark extends t the in
question mark super T these concepts are
not new they just have a new way of
expressing them okay now why do we care
about all of that material we just went
through
well because Kotlin by default it ships
you a lot of these things without
projections those read-only projections
namely you have a mutable list and you
also have a read-only list they give you
that for free as you saw in the
definition that I showed you list the
the read-only version it's just the
mutable version without keyword assigned
to the generic so they're not going to
ship that in every different way you
want it but you can easily create your
own by using variants at the out keyword
now we have that read-only behavior so
okay let's wrap that all up with a use
case we have talked about types which
bled pretty naturally into how we would
use them in generics but I just talked
for a while about generics and you might
be wondering why you care and I have an
answer I always have an answer so here
is a simple standard library function
that you might use it's a map I've
created an array it's empty so map
actually won't do anything but if I go
in and look at map it has generics yay
so they're useful we use them places but
if you go in and look at it even further
you'll notice it has types and a has
generics and it also has this word
inline and if you're curious type of
fellow you might wonder what is the deal
with inlining well let's build an
example to find out the key to this is
that it has three steps two of which
don't matter so the first one we can
create an array of the numbers one two
and three that's it nothing crazy
happening the last one we're printing it
again nothing crazy there we're
literally just printing that now the one
in the middle is the one that's
interesting because we just saw that the
definition of math is in-line and that's
what we want to explore so what is this
line doing well with the lambda
it says take the numbers one two and
three and map them to that plus one so
what you're getting out on the other
side is an array of the numbers two
three and four
just each one had a plus one added to it
so that's what it's doing now let's take
a look at how it's doing that if you go
in and decompile the code you're gonna
get something that looks a lot like this
now it's completely unreadable and you
probably don't want to look at it any
longer so I've gone ahead and I cleaned
it up and this is like what you would
get if you d compile it but then tweaked
it so it had better variable names and
basically that map with the plus one
it's you know creating a new ArrayList
and then it's getting the iterator of
the one that you want to map and it's
going through each of those values
adding one to them and putting them into
that destination array which it's going
to return so nothing crazy we're going
through a list adding one to each value
and storing it in our output returning
the output that's what that map is doing
okay so if we want to know what in line
does in the context of this example we
can go ahead and decompile this whole
function again it's just the creation of
the array that inlined function and then
the print so yes we can look at the
generated code it looks like this which
again is really really ugly and we won't
spend time on but it's here if you want
to look at it and so the cleaned-up
version is this and now we can finally
see what that in line is doing namely
this line here is exactly the same we
created an array yay and this line here
is exactly the same - the only thing
that has changed in that is that all of
that code that we saw that map is doing
it's now in our function it's here this
is an exact copy of what the map code we
saw earlier was doing but now it's
inside of our function so to answer the
question of what inlining does well it
injects code directly into the call site
and and specifically what that means is
that if we have a function who does
exactly one thing it prints a line then
what you're going to get is
this foo with the function invocation
will turn into foo with that line
injected it's no longer redirecting to
another function and then printing it
just takes the contents of that function
plugs it into the call site and that's
what you have now it's worth noting that
this applies to both lambdas and
functions so here we've changed our say
hello to have a print line exactly like
the first case but also a lambda and
what that means is that when we go here
and we have this inline function it
turns into the in line like this now
specifically if you're wondering how we
generated this well this is the the
definition of our function so we can
copy it in that's what inlining does and
now it applies to lambdas too so all we
would do is go ahead and copy in this
and this is what we get which is exactly
what you saw earlier that's how we
created this method I have an extra
bracket somewhere but that's fine oh I
have missing brackets somewhere so this
is how we created the function we copied
this and then there was a lambda and
then we copied the contents of the
lambda and now we're here that's what
inlining does okay
might ask well okay why why not use the
function like we had a perfectly good
function and then you copied it into
another one instead of just calling the
function that's a little bit weird well
the answer there is performance it's
always performance anytime something is
weird at the performance that's that's
like the number one go-to and and
specifically it's the performance of
lambdas lambdas have overhead and what
inlining does is it tries to get around
the overhead of the lambdas and that's a
little a little hand wavy and it's hand
wavy for a purpose which is that it
would take a long time to go into that
but if you're curious you can definitely
look it up and the way you know that I'm
not lying about it even though I'm not
going into it is that if you hover over
an inline function that does not use a
lambda you're immediately going to get
this warning that says hey using inline
with anything that doesn't pass a lambda
is not very useful you're really not
going to get any benefit
so you can do it but you're not getting
anything from it because again this in
line is aimed at lamda overhead so we
talked briefly about the who what where
why and when of lambdas namely their in
line in lining means you inject code
into a method you do that via the method
signature why do we do it because of
performance and when do we do it when
we're using lambdas now I left off this
one keyword which is how and if you're
wondering are there special cases to in
lining that I should be worried about
the answer is of course yes for instance
you usually don't want to inline lambdas
that are very large the reason for that
is that it copies all of the code in
that lambda into every different place
that calls it if it's 60 lines of code
in a lambda every place that invokes
that lambda in an inline format will
have all 60 lines copied and pasted so
that can lead to code bloat now there
are more reasons like these words cross
inline no inline I haven't talked about
them at all and they're scary and a lot
of people don't like them because
they're a little bit complex and
unfortunately because of that I won't be
able to do them just if if I if I talk
about them today however I don't want to
completely leave you hanging and so I
provided a link to the documentation
that explains these caveats and also
this is a jumping off point for Google a
lot of times if you are trying to get
into a concept it's hard to know which
key word to look for in a search engine
so I've provided those if you want to
learn more about inlining three things
that you probably want to know about to
make sure that you're doing it properly
is ray if I generics cross in line and
know inline modifiers I've given you
recaps of why you would care about these
but I'll post the slides and you can go
and google those later also cover them
in a talk in a future when I can do them
justice but for today that's all I have
for you thanks for coming to my talk
[Applause]